chris bassett on the mound for the
athletics says he makes his 10th start
he has had an outstanding season with a
4-2 record as sub-three-earned run
average
first pitch of the ball game is grounded
to tony kim and we'll pitch one out as
dickerson is retired
here's donovan solano swung on her
medicines out he goes to fastball away
quickly too when belt is coming up swung
on a high pop-up
short left field grossman coming on he's
under it now waiting for it
and he makes the catch so the giants go
down one two three with the a's coming
up in the bottom half
there's your starter tonight for the
giants logan webb
against the a's he's only faced him a
couple times he's on one
still looking for his first win tommy la
stella dh
today and he's batting 282 and this
pop-up may be playable
crawford a long run he's done this
before here and he makes the catch
a long way to go for crawford and
there's a lot of room to cover
in fog round in this ballpark so one
away and here is marcus
simeon simeon's taking inside marcus
walk so the a's
have their first base runner and cannons
coming up round ball to the right of
second
farda was left solano throws to second
and throws it past
crawford everybody is safe and the
ascent runners at first and second
not a smart play should have thrown to
first base get the second out
so now with one out the asset runners at
first and second we're in the bottom of
the first there's no score and matt
olson checks in
now a fastball struck him out swinging
two down in the first
and here's jake lamb what a start to his
a's career wearing the green and gold
he's five for eleven
and that's a swing and a shot and it's
going to be throw into right center for
a basic
one run is scored and jake lamb comes
through once again
if nietz take a one-nothing lead now
it's a matter of minimize the damage
and here comes shawn murphy swinging a
ground ball to second
solano's got it straightens up and
throws him out at first
the inning is over crawford is going to
jog into second base with a double
and the giants have their first hit and
that'll bring up darren rough
check swing and he goes on the appeal to
first and two k's in the inning on the
slow curve and the a's have two on
with one out and their best power hitter
matt olson coming up that one is drilled
right field down the line and that
baby's gone
what a lift that'll be for matt and for
the ball club
if olson can find his stroke here in the
final 10 days of the regular season
and that extends the a's lead to four
nothing gays are back in business
already leading four to nothing
runners at first and third with one out
for tommy la stella swinging a smash up
the middle diving forward to his right
of solano can't get it
and that will score laureano it's five
nothing a's and the a's continue to have
their way with logan webb
hard to watch tonight and now simeon and
that's a base hit left center field
kemp comes in to score and it's down six
to nothing
gabe kepler has seen enough and quite
frankly everybody in orange and black
has seen enough
and he will ask for andrew suarez with
canna and then olsen the heart of the
order up again
canna hits a change up off the end of
the bat slowly to first belt will take
it
two down with olson coming up for the
third time here's a slider
swung on and missed by olson strike
three so suarez comes out of the bullpen
and gets a couple outs
a couple of walks in the inning for bass
in his first two
and brings up wilmer floor now let's see
if they can make him pay for this he's
giving away
two base runners with a six run lead
swung out of miss on a curveball down he
goes 70 miles an hour
perfect pitch a thing of beauty it has
been an impressive night of work
from the a's right-hander chris bassett
so in the last six hitters
chris bassett has walked three here's
daryn ruff oh one bouncing ball left
side deep short backhanded by simeon
bobbles it
still goes to second they get the runner
crawford at second base
rough at first and joey bart will come
up for the third time hits a little
squiver past the mount toward the middle
kemp comes in to try to
barehand it the umpire guccione dives to
get out of the way
and everybody's safe but a good night
for chris bassett he goes six and two
thirds
leaves with a six nothing lead here
comes petite
so two on two out basketball is sent
toward loriano again
in left center field out into the
shadows he goes onto the warning track
makes the catch and the inning is over
two pitches and petite gets the job done
keeps
the shutout intact right-hander jordan
williams comes out of the bullpen to
work for the a's in the ninth inning
these blanking the giants is six
nothing swinging and a miss by crawford
is down on strikes
so here's rough a right-handed hitter
swung on and missed and ruff is down on
strikes
if these get this last out right here it
won't quite be official
the postseason clinch because they're
still on the top of the ninth
where the padres on top of the mariners
6-1 turns and delivers and it's swung on
and missed
and this ball game is over and these are
closing in
on clinching a post-season berth in 2020
and if that padre mariners score holds
the athletics will be in the postseason
for the 11th time
in the last 21 years what an
accomplishment for this
organization